let's go Marissa my name is Peter pack
welcome back to another episode of The
Walking Dead if we saw and we saw that a
really intense part so I'm curious to
play more but before we begin I do want
to address the elephants but how is the
expression I don't know I feel like
enough already okay I a I've been trying
to make decisions that are more
responsible and and how I would react in
the search situation I'm it might not be
the best thing in the world for
everything but at least it's my decision
and the point of the game is after all
to shape the story after the way you
play it
and if you don't like how I play I
really recommend just playing it
yourself and it should be interesting
because at least then we pick different
things and you can see it what what
changes and what not because because
usually like in some games series if I'm
not good at the game I'll try and
practice and so so it won't be so
horrible look at but in games like this
there's really not much I can do about
it we have different opinions and what's
the point of playing a game with choices
if I'm just gonna pick someone else's
choices anyway like I'm more than happy
to listen to you bros input and stuff
like that it's it's not that I'm trying
to shut you out I'm just trying to
explain that people seem to be
frustrated because I choose one tiny
thing over another and they think that
that's gonna have a huge impact of the
game but literally very little changes
in the main outcome of the game it's
more which dialogues and stuff like that
so don't try not try to just relax and
and enjoy it instead of being bothered
by which things I pick because they
really don't matter that much in the end
anyway
but without further ado let's keep
playing
because I freaking love this game I
think is awesome okay so we're back and
let's talk to Nick and see what the hell
he's doing cuz honestly what the [ __ ]
get your [ __ ] together Nick i'm
super-cereal
thanks a lot for backing me up there I'm
sure they're talking about me right now
becoming a danger to the group who was
that guy I swear it looked like he was
holding you guys up I figured he was
with Carver he was just a guy yeah he
was yeah Alvin is in front of me he
takes that shot what a [ __ ] mess
maybe I am losing it I don't know
anymore I don't think you should have a
gun anymore I'm hungry what time is it
anyway
damn damn what's wrong when I left my
watch back at the cabin
it was Pete's he gave it to me oh it's
all I had left of him you know what I'm
gonna go talk to them Wayne mm-hmm is he
gonna go back maybe he's gonna go back
no that'd be stupid all right let's find
some food see if we can find something
for that crazy-looking pregnant lady it
did say I had kind of food so it did
have a line so he was it other empty
what about in here open how do I open a
it's locked probably yeah I don't see a
key around here that man probably had it
oh well we're just gonna have to find a
way to open it then a survival knife
I really hope the guy was lying and he
was just mean or something cuz I feel
terrible that he got shot that was just
not right good but I also hope that I
think he's gonna come back because he
wasn't I guess he slept here
he wasn't it wasn't dead when he fell
off it's dead that one is dead though
are we gonna go skiing that would be so
funny to see Clem trying to ski ski
mission with Clem she's go down the hill
and there's like zambese coming left in
mind she's like oh well you can dream
can't you alright let's use the knife
that's not a tiny knife man well I
wasn't that much
man not that we had a bad look at this
dump guess he did have food and [ __ ]
Nick Nick's lost a lot of his people
that's for sure but that doesn't give
him any excuse to start shooting up
strangers he was trying to help us yeah
and someone died ain't no judge but that
straight-up murder in my book I mean you
ever know anyone who'd do a thing like
that yeah oh yeah actually yeah what
happened a woman in our group her dad
died and then she just shot this other
woman I think that he'll what you do we
left her behind Dan oh no we can't leave
Nick behind I love Campeche that's funny
she looks just like you
[Laughter]
hey Clem there's not a lot of food here
and Rebecca
well she's eating for two you think we
can keep this just between us I hate to
even say it you know but and I'd never
go against the group but I've got to put
back in the baby first you understand
right Rebecca can have it I won't say
anything thanks Clementine
it's a shame Nick was a good guy he's
still a good guy he's just losing it God
knows we're not perfect
hell I'm glad your witness Clementine
because I'm awesome and super kawaii
hell is that oh oh oh no oh they heard
the gun shy walkers we got a problem
here
yeah we saw it all right we're heading
up
shamed it I thought they would used to
lift it'll be an awesome well what are
we waiting for
we have to be careful careful we've been
on the road for five days my back is
done be careful
doesn't look like anybody's home how the
hell did she manage to get pregnant in
here nailed down tight I'll check around
front I'll go with you
well be good to know if anybody's
actually back there could probably get a
better view from up top you'd have an
easier time getting up there you feel
like taking a look it'll be just like
climbing a tree house and just uh a
really tall tree house I had a tree
house once well there you go I hated it
so we're gonna climb that huh just take
it slow and I'll catch you if you fall
probably just like the first time we met
got a good grip yeah when I was a kid we
used to jump rooftops downtown now that
was fun that sounds stupid yeah yeah it
was the trick was not to look down
though something's gonna happen while
we're up here for sure
and we're not gonna be able to oh [ __ ]
oh oh you're fine you're fine just look
at me okay you're fine
I just just slow down just for a second
okay keep your voice down what you just
yelled at me shut up hey I didn't mean
to reply like that I just thought I
shouldn't yell if there's damn bees and
stuff I thought that was like the thing
I didn't mean to be sadly clam okay oh
cool that's pretty awesome actually
hey crow made it hey crow [ __ ] you see
anything I can see the bridge there's
people coming there isn't he how do I
say about it
wait I see something what is it a light
but wait there's another Luke
Luke
huh
told ya
where the hell are those what the [ __ ]
what is this
listen everyone just stay calm are you
are you trying to rob ah excuse me honey
but do I look like a [ __ ] thief oh
sure everyone calm down
hey man you calm the [ __ ] down Sarah get
behind me tell us who you are
we ain't here to rob nobody put the gun
down on that whoa whoa what whoa please
just do what he says
what no no what honey wait you know this
guy Clementine
how the [ __ ] did that happen
I'll take that as a yes these people
with you
how misty moustache-man we can talk
inside great I just started dinner
are you sure you don't mind it's gonna
storm so please come in
the fields are coming back may know
that's a huge housing I want to hear how
the [ __ ] he made it though they have it
looked like he packed some weight to the
place is nice
Norway Wow Italy well Jane Sarita have
been staying with us for several weeks
used to be a ski lodge obviously so we
have plenty of food and believe it or
not we still get some power from that
wind turbine out front we tend to keep
most of the lights off at night to avoid
drawing attention but after we found
this stuff in storage we couldn't resist
making an exception Oh what's funny oh
nothing Walt
Walter here's one smart sumbitch makes a
mean can of beans too well why don't you
two catch up while I get some dinner
started
it's nice please make yourselves at home
you can leave your things over there the
hell we will yeah I'm holding on to my
rifle Thanks how about you don't you're
our guests here there's no need to worry
tell him to put his gun down then Kenny
will you vouch for these people clam if
you tell me they're good then I'm us you
were the one waving a gun around man
we're cool
no God Oh God I need to think I'm sorry
oh wait never mind cool we're cool
they're calling time they're cool
they're cool they're not cool they're
not really cool dad look Christmas John
now Sarah isn't it great we found it all
in storage it's amazing they look very
similar
[ __ ] love this episode so far it's
awesome but how the hell did can you be
gay if you'll all follow me I'll show
you where you can sleep
I thought it for sure I thought we're
sure Lily was the one who's gonna come
back because she's the only one we
didn't really okay
let's talk you know what let's talk
still wearing this dirty old thing huh
you know I half expected to see Lee walk
up next to you you guys were like two
peas in a pod
mmm oh [ __ ] I didn't mean to it's just
hard not to think about it you know he
saved me I knew it I knew he would that
guy had a fire in him sure as [ __ ] hell
Lee and I had our differences that's for
sure but when my son well he was there
for me
sure was so where'd you end up
I was with Krista and Omid Omid well
Krista and I were together for a while
but these guys caught us she's gone
sounds like it ain't been easy for you
I'm sorry darling I wish I could have
found you sooner but everything's gonna
be fine now where have you been oh hell
all over after Savannah how did you get
out of there for some reason I tried to
save that [ __ ] [ __ ] man
I turned into a damn cluster couldn't
help the kid but I got out long story
short I got lucky
real lucky eh must have been spent a
long time alone after that it
and then I met Sarita thank God
gosh it's great to have you back you too
catching up clam this is my girl Sarita
ain't she beautiful nice to meet you
Clementine
hey Walt where's Matthew he's still out
there rooting around of course he is
well I'll start dinner Carlos right mind
if I steal your daughter for a secret
mission stay in Psych sweetie
can we do anything to help could use a
hand outside we've got a lot of supplies
to bring in before that storm hits and
those lights out sign before those
people and why don't you help Walt with
dinner mmm this is not a good idea we're
gonna get a tag and no one has a gun
Clementine settling in well enough yeah
thanks excellent want to help me prepare
a little dinner sure why not if it
you're missing like any he and Sarita
had been a huge help Matthew and I
barely knew what to do around here the
first week we're old friends I met him
after it happened when he was with Lee
yeah he only told us a little connecting
with people is so important I don't know
what I'd do without Matthew gosh you
remind me of my students I can't imagine
what it's like growing up in the middle
of all this
everyone underestimates me I expect
you've used that to your advantage
sometimes smart girl almost done
would you do me the honor of tasting the
first course madam what is what is this
Leigh Walters surprise an autumnal
legume salad with a peach room it's
peaches and beans it's all we got
huh striking resemblance
anyway I'll take it from here
that was awkward
look around the lodge hope you guys
enjoyed watching this one it's getting
really really really really interesting
I don't happen back that would be a
great time to leave like for us hope
you're nuts and never heard about the
deficiency awesome love you guys see
tomorrow